M Canada, mes concitoyens canadiens, je
vous parle depuis une écluse de la
Colline du Parlement, tout juste sortie du
confinement. Je suis profondément attristé par les
événements horribles d'aujourd'hui ici à Ottawa et je
condamne sans réserve ces
actes de
violence brutaux et sans cœur. Cette attaque est
impardonnable si d'autres
les auteurs ou les co-conspirateurs existent,
ils doivent être arrêtés et punis
avec toute la force de nos lois. J'ai
offert mon plein soutien au
gouvernement ainsi que tous les
membres assistants de notre parti qui peuvent apporter en ce
moment mes pensées et mes prières.  avec
ceux de mes collègues, je rends visite à la
famille et aux amis des victimes de l'
horrible fusillade d'aujourd'hui, notamment le
caporal Nathan Frank Cerillo, qui
gardait consciencieusement l'un des
monuments les plus sacrés de notre pays. C'était un
acte lâche qu'un homme non armé ait été assassiné
de sang-froid à  les mots rapprochés
ne peuvent pas exprimer la profonde tristesse que nous ressentons
suite à sa perte face aux courageux femmes et hommes
qui se sont précipités sur les lieux pour affronter le
tireur et pour nous aider à assurer notre sécurité. Je dis
seulement merci, merci pour votre
courage altruiste et votre
professionnalisme dans  cette période de
crise dans les jours qui suivront, il y
aura des questions de colère et peut-être de
confusion, c'est naturel mais nous ne pouvons pas
laisser cela prendre le dessus sur nous, nous perdant
dans la peur et
la spéculation est l'intention de ceux
qui commettent ces
actes odieux qu'ils veulent ébranler.  nous, nous
resterons
résolus, ils veulent que nous nous oubliions nous
-mêmes, nous nous
souviendrons nous nous souviendrons de qui nous sommes nous
sommes une démocratie fière, une nation accueillante et
pacifique et un pays à
bras ouverts et à cœurs ouverts, nous sommes une nation d'
équité, de justice et de  l'état de
droit, nous ne nous laisserons pas intimider de
changer, ce sont plutôt les
valeurs et les principes auxquels nous devons nous
accrocher encore plus fermement, notre attachement à la
démocratie et aux institutions que nous
avons construites est le fondement de notre
société et une croyance continue en  les deux
nous guideront correctement vers l'avenir,
rester fidèles à nos valeurs en temps de
crise fera de nous un exemple pour le
monde entier. Les
criminels ne peuvent pas et ne nous dicteront pas
comment nous agissons en tant que nation, comment nous nous gouvernons
ou comment nous nous traitons les uns les autres.
ils ne peuvent pas et ne veulent pas dicter nos
valeurs et ils ne peuvent pas décider de la manière dont
nous utilisons nos espaces publics communs
aujourd'hui. Certains parlent de la perte de l'
innocence au Canada, c'est
inexact. Le Canada n'est pas et n'a jamais
été innocent face aux menaces auxquelles nous sommes confrontés et
nous  sachez comme nous avons toujours su que nous
ne sommes pas à
l'abri, ce qui est vrai, c'est que nous
n'avons jamais laissé ces menaces nous façonner et nous ne nous
sommes jamais pliés à ceux qui veulent
saper nos valeurs et notre mode de vie,
nous sommes restés Canadiens et c'est
ainsi  nous continuerons, nous obtiendrons des réponses
sur comment et pourquoi cela s'est produit, ils
seront essentiels pour prévenir toute
attaque future et pour nos amis et
concitoyens de la
communauté musulmane, les Canadiens savent que des actes comme
ceux-ci commis au nom de l'Islam sont
une aberration de  votre
foi a continué La coopération et le
respect mutuels aideront à prévenir l'influence
d'une propagande idéologique déformée se
faisant passer pour une religion. Nous avancerons
ensemble et non
séparés dans les prochains jours. Nous ne serons pas
inondés de photos et de vidéos
montrant ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui, mais il y en a
une en particulier que nous  devrions tous nous rappeler
l'image que nous avons en tête des
Canadiens aidant et protégeant
les Canadiens, c'est qui nous sommes vraiment et c'est
qui nous continuerons d'être bonne
nuit
gouverner
naan
Frank
Prof
pour
Dem
pour pour can
pour
Contin